mitch kessler my co-host was fired today
the network that i gave 20 years of my
life is now locking me out
you left me in the woods with a pack of
wolves i am so mad at you there had to
have been a million and one women out
there who did work on the morning show i
think that you're jealous because of our
history you're not impartial on this
subject and you're impartial
it's a good time to start grooming some
new people i just need to be able to
control the narrative so that i'm not
written out of it you don't have the
power anymore we are doing this my way
my new morning show co-host is bradley
jackson
[Music]
your show sucks oh thank you it's barely
news was there something about the
network that made it impossible to
complain what the hell is she doing did
you know about mitch
i'm down the road on an investigative
piece looking into the upper levels of
uva we didn't know right right
i want you to interview me on the show
i can give you who else knew about what
was going on we have an opportunity here
to do something truly meaningful this is
dramatic thrilling
he wants everybody that includes me
bradley's got to go you and i would make
a great partnership you have no idea how
much i've waited to hear these words
[Music]
you said you had someone who could
corroborate fred's direct complicity
she's dead
are we doing this we would like to share
some information about our network get
everything
there are some really bad things going
on here none of us are going to lie to
you anymore we cannot accept a culture
of silence
you